[Musique]
des erreurs
le cerveau de gregory charles a
emmagasiné des milliers de chansons
voici son secret
ça bien
grand pâle au travail j'ai rempli sur le
faisons dans la vie sous peine de
commencer une bataille
très tôt sa mère lui a montré à
mémoriser des chansons à l'aide d'un jeu
de simulation de répertoire maman
malaisie mois d'automne avec vaste aux
premiers temps de la valse tout seul tu
souris déjà qu'ils trouvent à d'autres
choses là qu'une vaste
j'ai fait comme chostakovitch ayant eu
des parents tous les deux ont eu des
démences
je les fais encore plus consciemment men
parce que je me dis que plus je tiens ce
occuper plus tiens ça en fonction et
enfants plus longtemps ça va ça a
fonctionné
j'aime beaucoup les réseaux champions
annonce tas de raisons qui devenus
adultes
gregory charles a trouvé ses propres
jeux de mémorisation et entre deux
spectacles
ils écoutent de la musique trois heures
par jour et c'est en grande partie dans
son automobile qui la prends c'est quoi
en ce moment on écoute mathon chambre
parce que j'ai envie d'entendre sa venue
chez leurs amis qui date de 2003
passionné de musique et d'histoire
gregory charles a aussi des centaines de
petits cahiers où il prend des notes
je me remplit des calepins alors je leur
avais dit 4 peuple je m'écris mettant
juste les beats hausse de mémoire
qu'est-ce qui se tient en ce sens les
deux caisses qui s'en sort des trois
caisses qui sauf dans les cas plus après
ça à côté je m'écris c'est sur les
tonalités d'origine de ces de ses
chansons légères part sur un calepin ici
le jury a dit qu'elle a ni comment mais
ce calepin là il commence à 17,68
gregory charles a interprété plus de 12
les chansons
sur scène mais ce n'est pas assez
j'aurais envie d'oser le pays avancés si
je suis en train de créer la prochaine
génération de saut à skis car ma fille
dans la voiture je joue je joue à ce jeu
là avec le gia je vais te faire de la
musique stand fille de quel film ici
louis fait des poules mais radio-canada
montréal
[Musique]